des véritables stars sur les réseaux
sociaux que ça faisait tuer pour par
plusieurs millions de personnes
honnêtement c'est vrai que ça a été
beaucoup dit aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas
peur que d'être moins suivi si vous
partez départ c'est parce que c'est ça
coûte ça peu après il est revenu
franchement il ya plein de personnes qui
ne font pas télé à une téléréalité qui
s'en est ensuivie énormément on va dire
que maintenant il y en a qui font de la
télé qui sont pas suivies du tout
[Rires]
fatigué très peu mais c'est madame
premier degré oui des trébéens compte
instagram way to sah son bébé quand tu
fais ça tu prends une claque un oui
c'est vrai qu'il a 2 995 d'abris vous
ouais c'est incroyable je n'ai pas les
boules j'ai un peu plus simple est ce
parce que tu as les yeux petit mais
écrivait le petit filet alors qu'est ce
que vous allez faire maintenant c'est ça
que tout le monde envie de savoir
il est 21h 9 en engrais vous quittez des
marseillais mais qu'est ce que vous
allez faire c'est quoi vos projets ben
écoute on sait que ben c'était dans
l'air du temps qui ont quitté les
marseillais c'est vrai que du coup on a
eu pas mal de quitter la production
aussi bonifié prod non mais je sais pas
ça ne brasse tout le reste est adéquat
ouais là comme expliquer ce que ça j'ai
pas trop bien compris mais en gros avec
en gros et non oui et non on a en a on a
envie de faire plein de choses et bat
aux points en plus donc nature alors ils
vont travailler avec avec notre
production oui h2o productions donc pour
travailler sur un nouveau projet vous
pouvez dire c'est vous qui êtes venus me
voir pour me proposer le projet raconté
le téléspectateur c'est vrai qu'à droite
on a été approché par pas mal d'autres
productions pour faire pas mal de choses
c'est que non à la base on vous
conseille pas ce qu'on allait faire et
on s'était vu juste après sur carla
était passé et du cou
gt gt proposait carrément de savoir si
ça pouvait intéresser de faire quelque
chose autour de noms d'anciens jeux
qu'on en a discuté et on va faire votre
mariage
voilà voilà avec plusieurs idées
concepts par la exact contraire leur
mariage
[Applaudissements]
j'étais plus jeune je produisais des bar
mitzvah main tendue des mariages non
mais et il est un concept que j'adore
c'est vrai que il va y avoir que va
pouvait raconter à côté vous c'est votre
truc je t'en prie à les suivre notre
notre vie notre notre mariage avec nos
amis et à plein de plein de choses qui
vont se passer aussi entre nous et le
but c'est vraiment de suivre notre
mariage mais en même temps tous nos amis
qui sont avec nous notre ceva est plutôt
rigolo après mathieu normandie le gars à
un quart sont des deux voilà c'est
exactement
il ya beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est qu'il faut poser des questions et
si on peut en avoir d'ailleurs en direct
nordine ci se réveiller merci juste
est-ce que vous partez pas ce que les
gens disent est ce que ce qui a eu des
embrouilles
suite aux différentes affaires ont pas
du tout bien sûr qu'il ya eu des en gros
c'est pour ça qu'on est pas ou pas du
tout non pas du tout pas des précisions
avant on sait que même si on serait
revenu certes on aurait eu encore des
embrouilles mais au final quand on est
enfermé dans une maison 24h 24 on se
réconcilie c'est comme ça c'est vraiment
une décision qu'on a mûrement réfléchie
qu'on s'est dit maintenant à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui est ce que cette histoire
c'est pas venu au bon moment pour
rebondir sur autre chose
je pense qu à rien sans rien dans la 10
6 est tombé maintenant c'est peut-être
pour se diriger vers autre chose et
c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire